today the u.s is expected to surpass 12  and a half  million confirmed coronavirus cases  nationwide we're averaging more than 170  000 positive cases a day across the  country health officials are concerned  this week's thanksgiving holiday travel  will just intensify the surge  it's a natural reaction to say now wait  a minute  i know these people you know they're  friends they're coming in  you tend to almost intuitively and  instinctively let you let your guard  down  officials are asking americans to stay  just with immediate family and not  travel for thanksgiving and in los  angeles they're forcing visitors to sign  a form  acknowledging california's 14-day  quarantine